I was gonna ask you like a
who would you consider because again
like I hear so much obviously I hear the
Texas in you but when I hear you I'm
like man this motherfucker's rapping
like
he I'm just curious who your influences
are bro who are you listening to as far
as rapping yeah like who's so like when
I was my mom it was like a bunch of
UGK so I UGK Lil Wayne that was it yeah
that was it but when it came to my dad
it was no rap like my pops would listen
to whatever was on the radio but other
Medics Isley Brothers this is a bunch of
slow stuff yeah yeah so I feel like that
that's like you can hear that in my
music you know what I'm saying and so so
as far as this influences I ain't really
I didn't want to be a rapper so I never
just was like oh I look up to this
rapper I want to be like that rapper I
mean what was what was the dream before
hip-hop was a football I was a football
player yeah you were like going to try
to really were you I could have went to
the league lineman yes sir by the way I
I mean that was an obvious of course
have you seen this guy he's got it yeah
I played middle linebacker at first
and then but I was like I was
I was fast but I was too big to play
middle linebacker yeah so they was like
let's put you on the end and I got on
the DNA was okay like too small to play
this so
they they actually made me eat they made
me so what were you defense attack or
offensive lineman I started off as a
middle line but I don't know you talking
about what did you end up like yeah I
ended up for sure for sure the wall to
protect the quarterback yes sir somebody
had to do it what was your uh like like
how far did those aspirations go did you
end up playing in college yeah I went to
college I played college football for it
I went uh for a semester but I was just
homesick I was bored Minnesota oh like
the Badgers so I was in I was supposed
to but I had to go do uh it was only
supposed to be a year at like this Juco
out there yeah and I was gonna transfer
the first semester
Minnesota is an interesting place
because it's like when we think of
Minnesota we think of a lot of whites
you know yeah but Minneapolis is a Vibe
I was in uh uh like princess from there
yeah he is that's crazy you got to pass
by his house to go to the Mall of
America it's just like a big it's like a
big ball yeah with purple lights on it
Incredible God Rest his soul rest in
peace so you didn't like Minnesota no
mosquito whenever it's not cold the
mosquitoes try to kill you and then
whenever it's cold
it's cold so it's never it's cold it's
the worst place to live yeah for sure
because it's [__] freezing
imagine having to play games in that
practice and that
oh I can't even imagine practicing in
the snow or in that cold I remember
imagined believing until I was down
there it was Hill yeah in Texas football
is a religion bro yeah High School
football is like I think a Friday Night
Lights and [__] yeah for sure it's like
really like [__] and it brings a lot
of people it feels like in Texas it
probably brings a lot of people together
otherwise wouldn't be together I feel
like that's why I'm I'm able to
like handle the rap stuff High how I
handle it because of football like
coach Groves you did an amazing job
because he he he he taught me how to
like really just with life in general
football helped me with a lot he just
gotta you know yeah discipline to make
it even to make it to a junior I was
looking for the word and he took it
right out of my mouth yeah because it's
a lot of fake
crazy ass stuff they're going in this
industry man and just that just helped
me keep my composure and just stay in my
Lane that's another reason why I feel
like
Adam I've been blessed and been able to
do what I do because I stay in my own
and I don't worry about nobody else if
you got something going on with this
person okay cool you got something going
on with this person okay cool ain't got
nothing to do with me I'm still I do the
song I do a song with the both of you
yeah I'm Switzerland I'm I'm in the
middle yeah I know I don't know they got
nothing to do with me I'm from money I'm
for I'm for taking care of my child